two years ago chef and restaurant tour
Ken peshotta had a dream he bought the
river rock in in Milford Pennsylvania a
Charming Town nestled in the stunning
Pocono Mountains just two hours drive
from Manhattan it was the golden
opportunity the White Town of armies had
come this way
but soon after we got the keys the dream
turned into a nightmare I was expecting
to reach a certain number on room sales
and I didn't hit one tenth of that I
don't think Kenny has an idea how to run
an inn and a few guests that do come are
far from impressed there's nothing in
the bathroom no shampoo no conditioner
soap nothing we have to go out and buy
some if I came in I would probably check
right back up it was like old it's
trying to be cozy but it's not it's
hideous if I wanted to stay at my grams
I could pack a bag and go stay at my
grams I'm not going to a BNB for that if
you buy an in you got to step up and be
an Innkeeper we need to fill these rooms
we really do
facing financial disaster Kem was forced
to move out of his house and into the
Inn I said Ken you're making the biggest
mistake my name is Anthony miserable man
Ken is now 48 Single Living and he's
crumbling in and hundreds of thousands
of dollars in debt the more the hotel
fails 2 868 and taxes are still good the
more controlling Ken becomes
he just takes everything out on us to
make our lives feel miserable just like
his
don't feel very good about yourself as
an employee kind of chips away at your
sense of self
I don't know what's going on I told you
I'd buy a little time so I finished down
here everybody's walking on eggshells
everybody's afraid to do their job they
don't want to yell that clip
come here [__] yourself
to quit it's a daily event yeah don't
get better here I'm
you know what you really need to grow up
and act your age or a 48 year old man
just get the [__] out of my face the
progression of events has just turned it
all into a hot mess and it doesn't
matter what we do it's just a hot
flipping mess
[Music]
wow
hello where's the reception
foreign
hello hello somebody's ashes are down
there bloody hell
my granddad's house hello
where's the reception ah this is it
basically should be out in a minute if
you like okay thank you very much well
hello nice to see you it's nice to see
you I'm Karen oshaw and it's a pleasure
to be I'm a little bit nervous then yeah
a little bit nervous yeah honestly it
was just like standing on my own oh well
I'm sorry I apologize for that um
confusing where's the reception desk
it's right here right this was the
reception desk can I just couldn't show
you something yes
I know I don't mind getting stuck in
well
yeah oh dear that is pretty bad yeah
that's not very pleasant that's not at
all Pleasant
uh so would you like to go to your room
uh yeah follow me this way
okay
how old is this place this hotel was
built around 1880s I think it was
decorated in 1980s it kind of looks that
way for the first time in the last time
it's been a while for the rooms there is
a closet over here they uh special
hangers just for me oh yep
wow wow I think the coat will stay
what is that
extra carpeting we just got new
carpeting here okay so it's uh save for
repairs I've never had free carpet in my
wardrobe before okay just check my view
oh look all those bugs and the blue
bottle is staying for the week
it's a nice little Forest of them down
here we give these to your cleaner sorry
it's like an insect Funeral Home
truthfully in the fall there was like a
ladybug problem you'd bring it in guest
and oh my gosh it'd be like you know 50
bucks in the room and so Ken and I would
take care of that to get rid of ladybugs
with people to stay
um now they've died and look at this
here
I think that's a cockroach to welcome me
on the toilet having a number two
I'm just like I can't believe it look at
that never had a cockroach committee
welcome me on on the John let's get out
of here well what else is on this floor
well this is the owner's quarters and
all these bits of furniture here do
people literally sit that seems to work
well to cover internet service out here
okay so this is the Wi-Fi chair yes it
really is I'm going to bear that in mind
if I need to check my emails
[Music]
it's very sketchy at best okay far worse
than I thought through Gordon's eyes I
was like whoa it's totally neglected no
I will uh I'll unpack and get ready for
dinner
welcome to Milford it's a joke how'd it
go it was horrible the place is building
something
my first impressions of vegan have been
Dreadful at least I can take my mind off
things with some TV nothing look at that
I knew those shitty hangers would come
in useful for something
come on I can't believe Mr Simpsons come
on damn
this is embarrassing 110 for this [__]
hole
it's the general hygiene cleanliness is
just shocking
wardrobe is full of crap and there's no
excuse for dead insects and the filth
everywhere it's like they've given up
and no one knows there's a hotel here
because it's just not fit
to rent these rooms out for the public I
mean look
this is what the bedrooms are like God
knows what dinner's going to be like
so far at Milford Pennsylvania's River
rocking I've discovered outdated Decor
bugs Galore look at that I've never had
a cockroach committing welcome me on the
John got a TV that last worked in 1982.
I've heard that the owner is a chef so
maybe the restaurant will be the River
Rocks Saving Grace okay
perfect
good to see you thank you and it's Ken
isn't it yes sir he's a American Bistro
outside yes is it a classic Bistro yes
everything made from scratch that's nice
you're a chef I trade yes I am are you
not in the Kitchen Tonight uh no I'm not
working online so you've retired from
cooking sunlight running the path maybe
or um running the other side I'm just
watching all the food and letting and
selling everything out it's hard to run
this whole place by yourself I have so
many years of experience I thought that
when he hired me he'd be able to let go
a little bit knowing that I could get
this job done but he just can't seem to
let go
um and how would you rate the food one
to ten seven or eight and if I ask you
to rate your rooms out of 10 what would
you give them four or five
I'm now [__] myself about dinner
let's hope that the food is better than
the rooms sure
[Music]
the concept of an American Bistro
serving fresh local food in the Country
Inn makes perfect sense but I can't make
any sense of this menu oh
um so I'm getting a little bit confused
because we've gone Mexican on the
quesadilla we've jumped down to Thailand
and then we've got Italian for the
calamari
American visa yes sir wow
um what would you recommend on the menu
we've got a house small trout I believe
that it's a golden trout from Northern
California it comes in Frozen
you're recommending the I.E frozen trout
from Northern California you know Chef
it's been only Frozen Once right your
head is sweating it's a little hot in
here you're dripping again it's me I'm
sorry I know I feel like I'll leak in my
[__] butt that's your bold head
who puts these ideas together that would
be Kenny chef
okay
um so give me a Thai sample players yeah
sure yeah uh entree dying to see that
I'm traveling around the globe in
Milford enjoy I'm appalled I was
promised an American Bistro instead I
get a sampling from around the world
I was expecting fresh food but I get
recommended frozen fish what's going on
here
are they made in house no they are not
sure thank you James
[Music]
frozen crab reheated and how can you
make a slice of chicken look so Bland
that would give that Thai experience to
my [__] doll
L6 is on the fire too I'm struggling yes
sir is he a local boy yes he is I think
left to his own devices he'd do very
well he's very limited on what he can
use for ingredient wise because he
doesn't do the shopping who does the
shopping now Kenny does the shopping so
he's almost like cut the balls of the
chef off yeah sure M6 M14 menu at the
river rock is pretty much outdated uh
it's Kenny's menu
it's been here for years I don't agree
with the menu but it's he's my boss he
pays my my salary and still gonna get to
that point where he just kind of burnt
out
[Music]
hi Gordon Emery how are you tough on
this one what'd you do here I bartend
and I help manage Ken's a chef and the
chef is cooking he's not allowed to cook
his own dishes yeah it's almost like
he's sort of cutting his balls off well
it's kind of what he does with all of us
are you ready
to strip your confidence won't let you
make any decisions executive or
otherwise it's crazy and it's a lot of
micromanagement why do you stay here and
I'm a loyal dog unfortunately I'd bend
over backwards for him but that Bone's
wearing thin
that's your Chef Ramsay that might be
the golden ticket
[Music]
thank you
Jesus Christ almighty it's like
someone's just dropped a [__] T-Rex
foot on my plate
honestly in fact that might be a small
Valdosta oh that's a small one yeah sure
I mean it's like a meal for eight that
valdostano can feed an Ethiopian family
of 40. you know what I mean
horrific this is not what I would expect
in a Country Inn it's worse than a nasty
Roadside Diner I feel like I'm eating a
[__] flip-flop with mayonnaise
can the owner looks like a zombie sleep
walk in towards disaster it's time to
get everyone together and see if I can
wake Ken up how much money are you
losing per month right now about five to
seven thousand a month and that's on the
decline correct if those rooms aren't
that busy
why are they so disgustingly dirty
they're they're dirty because I didn't
check them it's almost like we're
robbing customers
when I arrived you give your food seven
or eight out of ten yes but the food was
Dreadful
Seth how long you been cooking almost 18
years as a chef 18 years in the business
are you proud of what you serve
personally I don't agree with Kenny's
menu it's on the menu I want what I want
I know what I want you can't hold
people's hands in this business
if you don't fix this in they've all
lost their job
I honestly think that Kenny needs
somebody to open his eyes so that he can
see that everybody that works for him is
capable and more dependable and we're
here to help him increase his business
and make it successful and nobody's here
had hurt him I'm here to help
it's impossible because you
are not helping yourself
and it's not as if you're the captain of
the Titanic you're the [__] iceberg
yet you haven't stared at yourself long
enough in the mirror and actually
understood where the issues are you're
looking at them
good night
oh Jesus
I've had about all I can take for one
day
[Music]
time to get to bed but based on how
neglected these rooms are I need to know
exactly what I'm sleeping on my black
light will reveal any bodily fluids
previous guests have left behind
oh Jesus Christ that has got to be SEMA
this is Hotel Hell
[Music]
before my first night sleeping at the
River Rock Inn in Milford Pennsylvania I
decided to check it out with my black
light to make sure there was nothing I
wasn't seeing
and I was appalled to discover a vast
spread of bodily fluid stains has this
thing ever been washed people pay to
sleep in this bed
unfucking believable there is no way I'm
sitting on these sheets tonight luckily
I came prepared
oh [__] I forgot to turn off the lights
[Music]
oh man that was rough
hopefully a shower will wash away the
memory of those awful stains
foreign
[Music]
I don't think the staff or the owner
have any idea how revolting it is to be
a guest here I want you to come upstairs
with me I want to show you something a
place to order you time for a wake-up
call
[Music]
good morning good morning these are the
guests that have been staying in the
hotel now you've all experienced the
last 24 hours a sleepover and what I'm
here to do is to help fix this place I
can't do it without your feedback
my biggest complaint was this morning
when I took a shower I had water up to
my ankles before I got out my shower
head I probably showered from here down
because the shower head hit hit me about
here there was like bugs on the floor
and then I was sitting on the bed and
then I saw a bug on the door too I have
back problems and this morning it was
really hard to get out of bed just
because you can feel the springs
the big question for me is that on the
back of last night's experience who
would stay here again
a little raise of hands
[Music]
I probably wouldn't come to stay again
really no one
thank you very much thank you thank you
I hope Kelly's starting to see how his
lack of effort at the end is driving
guests away there's one more thing I
want to show him if this doesn't wake
him up nothing will I'm going to show
you something that is
pretty horrific
come in uh just stand over there please
three of you
[Music]
glass is on
brace yourself Karen
oh my goodness
that's what I thought I'd even like to
think of what I'm even looking at it's
like a [__] Galaxy this is foul
absolutely foul I'm Shell Shocked a
little bit it's disgusting it's truly
disgusting the CNS makes me sick to my
stomach oh dear
I don't know what to say I mean I'm just
so Horror Show
it was horrifying I was thinking how
many times did this room even been
rented without being cleaned for all
that to be there Ken you're running a
[__] hotel not a brothel it is
[__] disgusting start taking
responsibility
[Music]
I've discovered some disgusting things
at the river rocking horrific food to
give that to my [__] dog dead bugs
like an insect funeral home and have
worked out what the source of all the
problems is it's Ken and it's not as if
you're the captain of the Titanic you're
the [__] iceberg
[Music]
he's in way over his head and making
everyone's life miserable as a result
and his incompetence has let the in fall
into a shocking state
[__] Galaxy so I thought I'd even
like to think of what I'm even looking
at this is truly disgusting
it's a true slap in the face I apologize
to everybody who slept there before
that I put you through that I think it's
horrible
I hope Ken realizes now that there's
more to running an in than just owning
an in
this place needs to change and change
fast
yes
Elise just went to get stuff first up
the Inn needs to be cleaned so it's a
place fit for paying guests to stay in
I put the whole team to work to clean
the in from top to bottom
and I'm going to address the worst
problem myself well hello Madam
very well thank you is there any chance
I can put this through a wash yes what
do you need to buy buy tonight yes
definitely would you mind okay do a sort
of extra strong cleaning product it's
pretty Rancid
okay so be careful we'll be there thank
you bye-bye can we don't catch anything
[Music]
wow place is looking so fresh while the
staff finished cleaning the Inn I want
to have a snoop around the kitchen and
see if there's any more clues as to how
Ken is running this place
[Music]
why do I have to ask weekly for the fish
to be iced down do not take this sign
down do not take my pens by your own if
you use this drill replace it or buy a
new one with your paycheck
bloody hell Charming
can definitely have issues let's see how
if you eat these cookies take one to
your next job interview
I mean my God I'm surprised anyone still
[__] works here
there's God
is incredible that's not management
this is insane I can't believe Ken is so
passive aggressive with his staff I need
to talk to him and find out what the
hell is going on I come across all these
little notes about don't take this if
you do take it to your next interview
you tell me what's going on
I I don't like being taken advantage of
I have some hard times with things that
they do
why are you talking to them
aren't you leading them why aren't you
motivating them why aren't you getting
close to them
The Secret of any good Management's
about communication understanding
putting yourself on their level
maybe I look at it as they should be on
my level
are you kidding
come with me I want to show you
something
take a seat here Ken thinks he's
managing his staff but I think he's
bullying them he needs to see how he's
making them feel I've set up a monitor
in one of the bedrooms and I'm going to
force Ken to watch a staff meeting I
think this might bring about the change
this place desperately needs stay here
I'll be back in five
[Music]
I came here to help
what I'm frustrated about is what I'm
discovering I snooped around the kitchen
I come across this it's a cookie jar
take one to your next job interview
we call those Kenny's nasty grams
I mean
a joke or is this no that's real
I put those notes up because my staff
needs reminders for me to tell them to
do the simplest test
they can come off as degrading but I
don't know if they get the hint yet any
other way what in the hell is going on
look at this one don't take my pens buy
your own I think he hides behind he's
afraid of Confrontation it's passive
does that make you feel he causes us all
to be discouraged in the jobs that we
have there's so many people here that
really know their jobs well but we have
become discouraged and when people
become discouraged they don't do the
things that are necessary
[Music]
like this we're just spiritless he's
really just sucked the Soul at every one
of us
he's just a spirit sucker honestly
[Music]
I'd love Ken the owner of milford's
river rock in into a bedroom where he
can watch a staff meeting on TV if you
eat these cookies take one to your next
job interview the staff have told me his
management style has destroyed their
morale is this a joke
every day there's no gratitude like so
when you say to us why why are we like
this we're just spiritless he's really
just sucked the soul out of every one of
us individually over the period and
length of time he's just a spirit sucker
honestly
Emery's comments about me brought tears
to my eyes her especially because she's
one of my closest friends
it did hurt me what do you want to see
change from him let the people his team
do the work that he's hired us to do
this place can succeed providing that
you stay on track you've got to stand up
to him
let me go get him
I hope that seeing that finally got
through to Ken it's time to reveal to
the staff that he was upstairs watching
every word wow of what my staff thinks
about me it's Awakening
it it really saddens me because I would
do anything for them and I feel that
they don't see that
I need to change
I uh watched everything you said
and
I apologize
I never wanted to suck the life at any
of you
and uh
I think I control this place
But realize maybe I don't need the
control
you have a good team here and if we are
going to move forward
you have to give them ownership of their
own areas uh Seth yep you've got to get
that mojo back and I'm falling back in
love with what you've employed to do
uh Karen uh you care and that's what
being a good Innkeeper that little
Personal Touch
you should have a hold on the inside of
this business
and sort of filling the place like the
end Hotel manager so I want you to have
that level of responsibility
I think what I learned the most was that
I need to give people the opportunity to
run this place I can't micromanage like
I always did
I really hope that he backs off and lets
us all do our jobs he just has to put
the faith in us and I know that our team
can accomplish anything
[Music]
I think Ken's warm into the idea of
change but I don't feel I've got to the
heart of why he looks like a man under
such extreme pressure
sure thing come on in
there's got to be more to this than
money
yesterday in many ways I started to
believe you'd given up today we turned
the corner we've got to stay on that
track I thought I thought I'd control
this place and it didn't work it's not
working it seems like the pressure
you're under it's not just Financial
right
in order to buy this place I borrowed
from my brother I said I think I could
really make this work and and the price
is Affordable would you help me you have
to be met with the owners
he went to the truck says how much you
want me to write the checkout for
[Music]
my mother too my mother that wouldn't
happen without her help either I said I
could move to this Restaurant to this
place and the only way I could do it is
I need some money from you I needed
fifty thousand dollars
and she also said just take it
so both their houses are tied into here
[Music]
so this place fails you have let them
down
and yourself
this entire place wouldn't be here
without my brother and my mother's help
I want the business to succeed so they
don't have to have a worry I don't want
to ever let them down and you can't do
it alone
do you have a girlfriend in hell no no
don't take this the wrong way but it
needs a it needs a woman's touch it
needs a bit of a feminine approach it
needs that kind of love no yes it's been
kind of rough there's been no lady in my
life because I haven't been had a chance
to go out there and and even meet or
date women I just want to meet that
special person and just a big deep
breath
first time I smiled in a while I guess
the River Rock Inn has come a long way
from where we started the ones filthy in
is now clean and can the owner has seen
the error of his ways I apologize
I never wanted to suck the life at any
of you but before this place is ready to
welcome guests the staff need to
understand the true meaning of
hospitality this place is definitely on
the road to recovery but I think this
team needs some training so I've asked a
very special friend Ramesh saidwali from
Caesar's Palace
I can actually show them how it's done
hi Gordon good to see you how are you
I'm D thank how are you I'm great please
take a seat it's so nice to see you it's
great to see you so the customer focus
is critical isn't it very much and in
your mind what are the golden rules on
the first 60 seconds you have to
approach your guests with a big smile on
your face because it just opens all
kinds of doors find little ways to to
make a lasting impression on that guest
and let them know that their comfort and
their enjoyment is your primary
objective and it sounds simple but it's
not that simple if you practice all the
basics sure the rest of it will just
fall into place it has to be natural
people know when you're not being
sincere the good news is the team here
you know their heart is in the right
place but they are clearly lacking
training okay the owner doesn't smile
that often so okay all right let me go
get the team okay
thanks Ramesh Kelly we've got someone a
very special I want to introduce you to
please come through
I'd like to introduce you to a very uh
very dear friend of mine
please my name is Ramesh Ramesh very
nice to meet you he's from Caesar's
Palace Karen he's flown in from Vegas I
asked Ramesh to come and teach you how
to greet
customers
holy mackerel he's a guy that runs
Caesar's Palace coming to teach my staff
how lucky of a guy am I he's here to
help you and to show you within 60
seconds of those guests arriving through
that door what we need to hit First
Impressions go wrong they never forget
it okay why don't we have a look at what
they normally do stop straight away and
we restart okay
[Music]
stop as soon as you see a guest coming
through there you can come out here and
reach for the door open the door and
have a big smile on your face it looked
like you just lost your arm
here we go bollocks
okay put a lot more into it okay it's
Gotta Be Good afternoon it's great to
have you here welcome it was kind of
hard I'm gonna work to get better at
greeting people
good afternoon nice to have you here
Welcome To The River Rock Inn thank you
very much stop before he extends his
hand out to you you should have extended
your hand out to him I feel like I'm
being yelled at by a drill sergeant
you're out on the side of town your turn
Karen you have an incredible smile that
was a little nervous Gordon's in the
back and he's chanting you know you
could do this you could do this no give
it a pep talk here we go
foreign
I'm Karen Welcome To The River Rock
afternoon my name is James Sanfilippo
I'm here to check in welcome Mr Temple
Depot come right this way
I see that you'll be staying with us for
the next week yes ma'am possibly more of
course that would be wonderful we have
you staying in our king-size room which
is on the second floor absolutely lovely
room with a pretty view out the front of
the house so that's a nice place to be
nice
finally
lazy Karen is a superstar
she really is that was very well done
Gordon helped me realize that I have
people that I can rely on and instead of
being the Hands-On owner
I should be more of the overseeing owner
which I really need to be very well done
right
[Music]
now that Ramesh has taught the staff how
to make the right first impression I'm
gonna try and help Ken boost his
self-esteem which will make him a much
better Innkeeper Ken meet Barbie meet
Ken nice to meet you nice to meet you
I've flown in Barbie hatch a Hollywood
stylist to give him a new look this
one's a little bit too big for you a
different shirt maybe well bobby gets to
work on transforming Ken I want to check
out the Inn's website
and see if that's also in need of a
makeover
is this supposed to be the Wi-Fi Channel
I can't even get it any signal
one bar
there's an amazing competition this town
so
in order to stand out and sort of be
somewhat different you do need a great
website
my goodness the opening page of the
website looks as old and from
the interior of the bedrooms I mean so
dated it's like it's been put together
on a 20 budget shocking
he doesn't realize that eighty percent
of hotel bookings are done online today
so if you've got no decent website to
follow then you're absolutely screwed ah
Come Back to Me signal
I'm safe it's great it really works you
don't have to put on a parka you just
throw it through on your neck you're
done let's do it thank you so much
you're so welcome Ken's makeover is
finished and I'm gonna take him out on
the town but first let's see what his
staff think
you're new in Cooper very very nice yeah
yes very handsome
let's go
[Music]
I'm taking Ken to a local bar I think
that meeting the right girl will give
him a great confidence boost the sort of
positive energy that will light up the
river rock and make Ken a pleasure to
deal with
quite a lovely little place take a seat
how Dapper does Kenny look
he does doesn't he thank you
how could that man still be single no
Kenny's single oh we gotta find your
milk
invite him for dinner tomorrow
night yeah tomorrow yeah
so can we have a little toast to Kelly
finding a girlfriend to Kenny come on
girlfriend it was really great ego boost
I felt like the king boy he really set
me up
thank you very much
if I fail now I'm really a loser
good night
honestly I've never seen a man change so
much um let's just hope he's not late
for breakfast in the morning
hello ladies
my design team worked through the night
to transform Milford Pennsylvania's
River Rock Inn and now it's time to
reveal the changes to Ken and his team
good morning good morning how are we
very good good Seth how you feeling
great great excellent all this week I've
really put so much effort into get this
in back on track so I'm greatly
appreciative for your efforts it's only
fitting okay that we start the relaunch
with a proper sign take a look at this
[Music]
the old sign from the old restaurants
it's a beautiful sign River Rock Inn and
restaurants the best food and lodging in
the Pokemon how cool is that that's very
cool it's a nice beautiful it's
wonderful thank you okay ready to go
inside yeah excited let's go come
through are you ready
it's a beautiful place to live and stay
not a place you've got to come and die
first off we have a stunning car on the
walls gone is That Hideous paper so now
it's in keeping with a rustic charm and
all the bugs are gone too the changes
are just incredible I'm a bit
overwhelmed by them and Blown Away
totally Blown Away we've replaced that
dinosaur TV with a new flat screen
guess what it works okay replacing the
mattresses stunning linen oh my goodness
new table lamps and guess what gone are
the spunk stains Karen the only Milky
Way is from the skies above yes
Karen so what do you think I
I'm still a country inn but it's a
country end of the year 2012. let me
show you the room next door please
this is incredible
this is just amazing Gordon just did
wonders here oh by the way
I've updated your router okay so you
have Wi-Fi in the room inside the room
oh my God how cool is that amazing
I'm Blown Away you're Blown Away worn
away accidents
oh wow please come in wow look at look
at this come in come in come in
when I first arrived the check-in was so
confusing now the guests come in they
sit down we offer them A coffee glass of
water
and then
we'll go to actually booking them in
online
[Laughter]
how cool is that
anything now how do you spend on linen a
month a fortune a fortune underneath
tablecloths you had these stunning
natural tables which were just being
hidden at a ridiculous expense focus on
the linen upstairs in the room
before Gordon was here I just had a
restaurant now I have an inn I have a
destination I can't wait I'm looking
forward to the relaunch tonight we're
gonna have a lot of fun you like it
thank you yeah you like it
[Music]
with a new decor and ramesh's expert
training hello
River Rock
along with a newly inspired cancer
enjoy your dinner the river rock is in a
much better place time to go when I got
here Ken
honestly that guy was a hopeless
Innkeeper almost like someone had given
up but
yeah we've turned him around it's almost
like he's sort of he's got his mojo back
and now a river rock has every chance of
succeeding I tell you what I've seen a
lot of Skies but not quite a Milky Way
like that
[__] me as I prepare to leave guess I'll
arriving for the relaunch and I noticed
some familiar faces from the bar last
night and as promised they've brought a
friend how are you my darling nice to
meet you
oh you're the town
first impressions
he looks cute looks cute
nice
I can feel a good night coming on
[Music]
Joey I need three onion soups two fish
cakes and fish fingers with Ken trusting
his staff and not micromanaging he's
able to spend more time on the floor my
friends leaving time to charm the Mills
of Milford hello how's everyone tonight
and this is
I was excited to see them she was very
pretty I look forward to talking with
her here we go ladies
my first impressions of Ken you look
cute very
um
ladies thank you very much
[Music]
the Inn is buzzing and Ken has invited
some very special guests to see the
place at its best and this is my brother
oh how are you sir likewise good to see
you too and my mother hello Madam how
are you how are you very well thank you
nice to meet you it's no words to
express how proud I am I've done it
upstairs the guests are loving the new
rooms and downstairs they're loving the
fresh local menu their chef Seth and I
put together really really good
before I can leave there's one last
thing I need to take care of your cell
number please no not for me if I can
come on
amazing Hey listen thank you so much for
coming tonight I really appreciate it
thank you Ken come here now how are you
feeling I feel wonderful honestly at the
beginning of the week I thought you're
gonna sort of almost I suppose fall to
the Wayside but you bounce back and I'm
grateful for that thank you I'm grateful
for you oh and one more thing
[Music]
[Laughter]
cell number
you can't have a better wingman than
Gordon Ramsay oh yeah he gave me your
number it's in my pocket
no more sticky notes nothing let them do
it yeah okay
I love you this is the greatest thank
you so much Gordon made me realize that
I should be less than the Hands-On owner
who can't see the forest Through the
Trees from here on I'm empowering my
staff to make their own decisions and
I'm going to support them
no more micromanaging for me
[Music]
what a week what a Galaxy
[__] me
this is the historic Cambridge Hotel in
Upstate New York it's set in stunning
Countryside a few hours drive from
Manhattan
the hotel has 16 bedrooms and a large
restaurant and has had his doors open
for almost 150 years welcome to the
Cambridge Hotel ex military man and
local lawyer John imhoff persuaded his
family to help him buy the hotel in
2007.
I remember sitting in my hot tub smoking
a cigar drinking Bourbon and life was
good and I want to thank my wife
someplace nice for dinner so I'll said
to her why don't we buy the Cambridge
Hotel and then we'd have a place to go
he must have hit me at a weak moment
because I said sure
you hug with zero Hospitality experience
between them which one is a27 I don't
know the numbers the hotel currently
falls shockingly short of guest
expectations
and there's hair all in through here all
over these pillows be nice if we had a
remote control there's just gobs of hair
we've had remote control since when the
70s I'm not sleeping here we're checking
no way it's bad
when I bought the hotel I didn't intend
to be a Hands-On owner but I am always
at the hotel doing something one person
has to be in charge got 84 emails 17
from John
John is a control freak how we doing on
that chicken that's working hard we can
do better Chef he's ready to murder with
this menu there's a lot of restrictions
to it our budget's really tight the
creativity's kind of gone out the window
Brett um all the rooms clean yeah follow
the rooms coming in I am currently the
general manager X that's interesting but
John takes away my control I have no
control
but General John's Hands-On approach
isn't working nobody wants to stay and
the hotel is losing thousands of dollars
every month John wants to put every
penny that we have into this hotel and
that is something I am no longer willing
to do we are 750 000 in debt
but failure is not an option and I don't
intend to fail at the hotel unless I can
fix things and fast John and Tina will
lose their business and their home if
Gordon Ramsay can't fix us
who the hell else can
wow the real sense of grandeur
definitely some history here Cambridge
Hotel established 1885 home of pilot
mode
I've been Across America I did not
realize it came from here
good morning
good morning welcome to
the king uh Gordon and your first name
sorry my name is Brittany I'm the
manager I have you in room 117. that is
105 during the weekday and 135 on the
weekend okay I think Gordon's first
impression of the hotel is going to be
what the [__] are these people doing
the Cambridge Hotel rip yeah seriously
yes it's died you mean no rest in peace
is the ghost it's that uh live here
we are haunted oh come on there's a
little girl who supposedly haunts the
hotel
Alice
[Music]
oh my good God she looks like something
out of The Exorcist she was four years
old in 1913. when she died well I
believe in ghosts at the hotel
I absolutely believe in them I'm gonna
go up the stairs as well and oh God
are they the owners no I don't know who
they are those have been here this place
is littered with freaky pictures
what's upstairs there that is our third
floor why is that roped off because it
is not accessible to our guests
well that's where people say they are if
he goes up on the third floor
he is going to freak out this is your
room
oh my God bloody hell look at the
wallpaper
what's the post up though what is that
just there so there's no handcuffs
no okay so so it's not a sex thing
that's a really weird thing to have in
the bed
oh [__]
sit
welcome to the Cambridge Hotel thank you
I am not going to forget this day in a
hurry
horrible linen rough and nasty holes
look at that and the bed doesn't even
fit the base
honestly I've seen better linen inside
hospitals horrible
my bedroom is dated and uncomfortable
how could anyone think this was good
enough for paying customers bye-bye
it's gonna be the owners yes I'll be
right back with the owners
how dead they are
[Music]
Gordon this is Tina and Jordan imhoff
nice to see you nice to see you nice to
meet you sir John likewise good to see
you both it's quite amazing when you
drive up and you see the sort of stature
of the building yes sir isn't it
beautiful it's stunning until we get
inside
Hotel experience prior to this was what
very very little I mean I was
none none
so year One what was the profit we lost
about 350 000 the first year year two
250 000 profit loss loss so we're in for
six hundred thousand dollars within 24
months of business who's funding this
well um my mom and dad have put in
several hundred thousand dollars
wow um our children our children your
children yes yes Shea has put about 25
000 on credit cards Shea is your the
oldest daughter your oldest daughter
right it's a chef's um significant other
okay and so my youngest daughter just
lent us ten thousand dollars your
youngest daughter she's in college how's
your house on the line next yes it is up
for sale and we would live here we would
move on to the third floor where'd you
draw the line say stop this is not
working you're standing there like proud
[__] very confident very happy and like
nothing's gone wrong but taking money
from your daughter that hasn't even
started on the path of her career I
believed that we would be able to turn
it around I know but John I'm sorry your
parents money your family's money your
daughter's money I I do have a positive
attitude there's a difference between
sounding positive and sounding
full of crap
he doesn't know me and he doesn't know
the situation I'm a military guy I'm not
going to take Chef Ramsay's [__]
just met the owners of the struggling
Cambridge Hotel and discovered they've
borrowed money from their kids to stay
open I I do have a positive attitude
there's a difference between sounding
positive and sounding
full of crap
unbelievable Tina how do you manage I
don't know how I manage and I was very
close to Running Away several times wow
seriously
unreal thank you
I've been frustrated for years with him
not listening to me when somebody
doesn't listen to you for a while you
just give up
what is it about John that's driven his
wife and potential guests away I need to
watch the General in action
what do you do with the Hoover welcome
nice to see you sorry about the owner of
walking through with the Hoover are you
joining us for a sleepover or are you
joining us for dinner
tell me I'll help you
John Keys himself constantly busy but
he's busy doing all the wrong things
his non-stop fussing and fidgeting is
killing the hotel's atmosphere
[Music]
the tables in the bar might be cleaned
but I've got an eerie feeling the food's
gonna be filthy only one way to find out
how are you good my name is Philip I'll
be your server
thank you I'm a little nervous so am I
um what would you recommend well the
soup du jour today is a vegetarian
lentil vegetarian lentil yep and what
was the Super Jewel yesterday it was
also the vegetarian oh so soup every two
days uh actually it's longer than two
days
um I'll go for the pork and beans duck
comfy yeah
um pilot mode okay okay I think we're
done okay thank you
thank you very much chef
Chef orders up okay thank you get them
going brother get them going
I think the Gordon is going to love the
food
Chef rich is great
we put out excellent food you chef
[Music]
wow look at that this is the pork and
beans
holy mackerel
it's cold in the middle both of you yeah
just touch the meat there please
I can see why we've got R.I.P on the
front of the [__] reception those are
two medium rares right scooters Chuck
them in the oven please Chef ice cold in
the middle
tell them it's a sous-vide product we
cook it to order
it disappoints me a little bit that we
are boiling bags putting stuff in the
microwave I wish we could actually
cook with fresher food your Duck Hunt
feet
and Chef said the pork and beans was a
sous-vide product and it's cooked to
order
sous vide oh we cooked the bag yes
they're frozen frozen yes and this plate
that's frozen I think that's a sous vide
product as well do we have anything that
is homemade are the apple pies made here
the apple pies are made here okay can
you have it with the desserts please
sure thank you
so far everything has been terrible
surely the hotel signature dish is going
to be better how's the apple pie
it anymore I'm sorry but this is the
home of Apple most but if it's the home
of our mode it should be really badass
[Music]
okay wow
play Hello mode according so this is it
this is the that is the paella mode
[__] this plate is absolutely roasting
in the center has it been microwaves it
has
the apples are raw
if there's one thing I was expecting was
a decent apple pie and that is gross
I need to find out who's responsible for
the terrible food here
hello if Chef Ramsay criticizes Chef's
food where is the where is Chef I think
Rich will blow up because Rich does take
things personally I don't know where to
start to be honest
what the [__] is going on well tell me
what you don't like can you be a little
bit more constructive should we start
from the pork and beans Stone [__]
cold it's a sous vide product so you
don't even cook that no stupid no and
can you cook yes so why buy that in uh
price you buy a store bought frozen
piece of pork
boiled in a bag and serve it to me stone
cold in the center you're not even
cooking so you're just too lazy to do it
that's not true I am not least this menu
could be run now without you being here
yes that's the way I designed it this is
why you designed it
so you are lazy then I'm not a lazy
if Gordon calls me lazy one more time it
could cause a problem
might be going back to threatening the
body bag
the food at the Cambridge Hotel and it
was awful I think it's because the chef
is lazy but he's adamant he's not that
menu stinks of laziness I'm not lazy I'm
here 80 90 hours a week yeah you can't
call yourself an executive chef come on
do you know it's still bought I did why
would you employ a chef at two thirds of
the menu is still bought
and I think Gordon believes that I'm
incompetent in running a hotel but what
I'm doing is right your hotel became
famous for this apple pie right and this
is the dish that is trying to stop your
house being put up for sale to keep this
place going but I'm just what I'm trying
to say is there are so many Basics wrong
I could [__] cry I could seriously I
could cry too and look at the apples
look the apples are raw not even baked I
could scream when I see that and this
this was invented here and it's
thousands of restaurants across the
globe that have copied what you
originated have you got any idea how
lucky you are and it resolves to that
soggy undercooked soaking wet
piss pie can I have a quick word with
you for two seconds please I'm
struggling to understand what's going on
here I need to hear a woman's
perspective John
is smart in what he does as a lawyer
here I can't
get it in his head but between the two
of them they're about to take your
[__] house down him and John go back
and forth when I give suggestions it's
pretty much you know up and then it's
pushed aside and then John is making
decisions
you're about to lose your house I know
and he says we are going until I haven't
got another Penny to put in it he's
never run a business before no no and
he's never done anything in his life but
be a lawyer and a soldier that is it it
may have won lots of battles but he's
[__] definitely losing this war let
me tell you
finally a stranger is seeing what I've
been seeing and I'm hoping that John is
gonna take something from this and
either we're gonna make it go
we're gonna shut it up
[Music]
I've seen about as much as I can stand
at this hotel the outdated rooms the
cheap Linens and the pre-packaged food
how have things got this bad I've got to
get some answers
along with this place and who's to blame
problem is here is that we have to ask
to do something
we're not allowed to make a decision
general manager executive chef we have
to run everything through John make sure
everything else
someone that doesn't know how to run a
[__]
okay you want to run it you run it it's
[__] soulless it's littered with [__]
antiques that are broken it's got
horrendous pictures all over the [__]
place disgusting rooms food that comes
out of a [__] bag and I don't control
any of that stuff I'm not making
decisions I told Rich that I thought we
should cut our food costs
have you got the respect
from the owners to do your job properly
yes or no no I have energy talk
I definitely do not make the decisions
that I think I should be able to though
she's telling you that and that's what
the problem is
[__] ghost John that's scaring the
regulars away it's you
a chef needs to be a [__] chef and
the general manager needs to General
manage I'm not a micromanager
when we first started this place and the
ideas I had were all shot shot down
that's the kind of stuff now it's coming
out you've handicapped the chef the
general managed this functional and
you're calling all the [__] shots I'm
not calling the shot you're a Lethal
Weapon well you may think that no I
don't think that I [__] know that no
just heard from your wife your general
manager your Chef that I'm controlling
Over Control you're like a little
[__] Hitler around here and if you
don't stop doing what you're doing
you lose your family and The Business
[Music]
foreign got to the truth at the
Cambridge Hotel you like a little
on the owner's meddling ways have made
everyone's jobs impossible I'm not a
micromanager they're not puppets
they're your team and if you don't stop
doing what you're doing you'll lose your
family
and The Business
working out your honor hung into bed
good night
this is all stuff that I've been trying
to get across to John for 20 years
hmm
what's the matter
seriously yeah what's the matter with
you right now we have a headache again
I've had it
I have had it I was feeling squashed and
I don't have to feel that way anymore
I'm not going to feel that way anymore
bedtime and I'm not looking forward to
sleeping in a haunted room I've never
seen such a delusional owner
and staff that are so desperate to do
their jobs
are now going to sleep in this
Christ Almighty
oh what the [__]
this bed is so uncomfy
why is that noise on the stairs
I had a sleepless night and believe me
it wasn't a ghost that kept me awake it
was something far more frightening time
to give John and Tina a wake-up call
after you please
laughs
hi guys
[Music]
these are the guests that have been
staying in the hotel I've asked them in
my room this morning as to help you
understand how difficult
I come for guests actually stay here
who'd like to go first I took a shower
this morning and used what I thought was
a clean towel and there was hair in the
towel yeah the batter himself was
actually very uncomfortable yeah
we left our room last night and couldn't
lock our door so we had to leave our
hotel room door unlocked
hand on Hearts how many of you would
return here yeah anyone
not unless you pay me to stay here
John and Tina are you aware of so many
problems inside these rooms
but I'm more
pissed off about about anything is that
last night I went downstairs
in fact let me show you it's easier if I
do it this way I forgot my toothbrush I
went down to the car
and I cannot believe this just watch
carefully
I went outside
so step down the stairs
and all of a sudden damn I let myself
out I've got no keys to get back in
the bloody front door
is not locked at night now
there's no night Porter
there's no security and then
shock horror
I went behind the reception desk and
every one of your keys is hanging
replicated in the pigeon box
wow that's terrible
duplicate key for every room oh my God
credit card details personal cell
numbers it's all there yeah
why is the door not locked
there's no good reason yeah we haven't
locked in a long time though no about
two years in this community you have
eight major burglars in the last 12
months three registered sex offenders
locally in this community I mean how
does that make you feel that we were
sleeping in this hotel last night and
each and every one of us
can you stay here with me and ladies and
gentlemen thank you
thank you John and Tina have broken the
first law of hospitality keep your guess
safe John's so busy interfering with
other people's jobs he's lost sight of
what really matters
I'm not
hilarious
Jason can be over in seconds on one
incident in this hotel
because you're not going to walk around
this town
has a prosecutor a chief lawyer and then
be responsible for a serious rape taking
in place inside here
wake up
you're running a business not a
courtroom
and they're here for an experience not a
[__] sentence
sell the place because you're not fit to
run it sell it
because this is madness
sell it
and keep your house
worth it
[Music]
I've just discovered that John has lost
sight of the big picture at the hotel
the bloody front door
is not locked at night and his
incompetence is putting the guest safety
in Jeopardy that's not okay
John doesn't change his interfering ways
he and Tina will lose their home and be
forced to live in the hotel's top floor
it's time to find out what it's like up
there
[Music]
hello anyone there hello
oh [__]
bloody hell
who in the hell we'll put this here this
really is Hotel Hell oh my God Welcome
to our hands
this place is genuinely disturbing
freaky
laptop floors no place to live but I've
got a plan if I force John to see how
different things could be here maybe
he'll get the message so I'm gonna need
Britney's help if we can prove to John
and Tina if you take charge and you hold
those reins but you can make money for
this hotel
trust me they back off and you step up
okay yeah absolutely I'm here I'm hoping
to prove to John that it can be busy it
can be fun here tonight we are serving
we are doing a bar night oh my God this
is terrible we're not a
rowdy kids doing shots going crazy bar
as a party party
we're gonna do a drink specials we can
get people in the rooms a ladies night
tonight have to pack the place thanks
bye
this is the first step to change as last
minute preparations take place in the
bar in the kitchen there's a new energy
in the hotel
this is Chef Richie's chance to prove he
can cook with fresh ingredients nothing
out of a bag please no preheated all
fresh yeah all fresh great Rich it's
your responsibility to teach these guys
how to cook absolutely not to reheat is
that right scoop yeah yeah absolutely
you just start a culinary school oh good
man I don't inspired you to be a chef I
heard relatives everywhere pushing me to
join a culinary field because I wasn't
physically able to do any other things
like sports and stuff yeah what's the
disability I've had two heart surgeries
and two back surgeries
yeah you move fast that's a big asset
they haven't been taught properly yet
have you no that's incredible so what do
you want to be when you grow up
um I would like to have my own Bakery
and be a professional executive pastry
chef wow we're ready to roll
Britney has gotten the word out that
she's in charge tonight and people are
flocking into the hotel there you go
okay let me ring them up ladies night is
going really well tonight there's a
mixed crowd of Ages here and everyone
hanging out together and having fun what
can I do to help you nothing get out
all right that's going great but I don't
think John quite understands how
important nights like this are because I
don't think this guy gets the message
John
I want to show you something come with
me
[Music]
everything Spooks me every time I come
in here
's the situation
downstairs currently there's a bus
and they got put together by your
general manager Brittany
that's her vision but if you carry on
running
the Cambridge the way you have been this
is what you're gonna have this is what's
your destiny this on your own so stay up
here
and sort of enjoy your surroundings
I'll come and get you when I'm ready all
right
he's so wrong he has no clue and I'm I'm
thinking when he comes back up he's
going to ask me what did I learn and I'm
going to say at home I really didn't
learn anything
pluck damn it
I've locked John the hotel's interfering
owner on the top floor I need to
demonstrate to him how well the hotel
can run without him
I'm not happy sitting there waiting
because I know my guests are downstairs
having a party
and I kind of felt that I needed to be
downstairs
supporters wants me to sit up here and
and think that he's all right about all
this stuff and dammit he's wrong talking
about me being a control freak
with ladies night in full swing chest
fiance
and John Tina's daughter Shea arrives to
join in the fun
I think she's my last chance of getting
through to join hi Shane hey how are you
I've got one minute 30 seconds please
excuse me thank you
time's running out for you Dad for your
mother and for their house I can't get
through to your father
I asked him to go upstairs and just sit
and Ponder and think that this is your
future then you think he's ready to
change by all means bring him down and
if he's not I don't care
keep them out of there and keep him up
there
hip-hop session what's going on I'm just
up here
sitting down and waiting waiting to go
back downstairs
I think the point
um
was to try and visualize what
could potentially be
the future oh no I've been doing a lot
of thinking okay I've been doing a lot
of thinking
I thought my role was about the same all
along
I feel like it's changed a lot and I
think a lot of it is
a fear of trusting
you don't have to be here all the time
when was the last time you sat down at
home and had a dinner with Mom you know
yeah I feel guilty when I'm not here
do you know what's going on downstairs
no
it's awesome there is a restaurant full
of people that are thoroughly enjoying
themselves it's happened
and it's working without you yeah
yeah I'm I'm getting it okay I mean I'm
um it's going to be tough for me to back
walk of the working I think it's
important for you I think it's important
for you and Mom
yeah you're making good points Jay
I think you would be able to spend more
time with your granddaughter oh I'd love
that
it's possible
you don't want this to be your future
you don't want to live here no I don't
you have to commit to change yeah yeah
I I understand if Mom will put up with
me being home more
love you I love you too Shay
I've I it's an epiphany I've I've just
now realized my control is what Dre is
dragging the hotel down now I need to
make a change in order for my personal
life to improve and for my business to
get better
thank you
tonight has been a real success seeing
Brittany in charge and Rich cooking
fresh food gives me real hope but is
John capable of letting go
my goodness it feels weird it's sounding
so quiet now right all right well done
behind the bar well done in the kitchen
scooter well done ladies great I mean
you can get a a seat at the bar within
20 minutes that's how it should be how
much do we take it's under 1400 in two
hours fourteen hundred dollars
in two hours we made more than the last
four Wednesdays or four Thursdays
combined Johnny you spent the majority
of the night upstairs how was your night
it was in a very good night actually
in what way
um my daughter Shea um opened my eyes to
some things I'm here every night because
I feel that I need to be here that that
is my role as the owner to wave the flag
as a military term but when it came from
Shea as she says you know Dad
I know how hard you work and and I
promised I wasn't going to tear up
and uh this all happened without me you
trust your subordinates as a commander
the most important person you have are
your ncos and Chef and Brittany are my
ncos I can't tell you how good is to
hear that because you're a [__] tough
nut to crack
because we have got one hell of a day
tomorrow
but I need everybody everybody at their
best
good job
what a day
I'm hoping that John has finally got
that message but is it all loyal crap
tomorrow we'll definitely find out
freezing
[Music]
coming up I dragged the Cambridge Hotel
into the 21st century and one of the
hotel staff gets some shocking news
my design team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal the new Cambridge Hotel
to the staff good morning
key let's go let's go
the door is locked so your guests can
sleep safe and sound come in unlocks
good good right come upstairs
I'm hoping you're gonna love my room I
think it's absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
oh my God look at the floor wow
taking the carpet out and putting that
flooring in absolutely transformed it
the wallpaper was expensive in order to
enhance it we work with it so we've got
the back drapes above the vet we have
this amazing new floor yes yes perfect
furniture that fits the room
we've upgraded every room with brand new
linen and towels 75 000 worth of linen
oh my God
we could have never afforded them that
that is so wonderful I feel like kind of
like a kid that comes down Christmas
morning and there's so many things under
the tree that you're you're in overload
I can't really comprehend everything yet
I mean I'm just kind of looking at it
saying wow
ready for more room oh my God I don't
know if I can take it
wow wow wow wow
I can't wait to actually show a guest
upstairs to a room I love it I love it I
love it
um there's one more little thing I want
to show you downstairs come with me
please in the 1890s the Cambridge Hotel
gave birth to world famous pilot mode
and I think that dish can put the hotel
back on the map today something I
thought was a huge missed opportunity
I've been working on an amazing very
special
apple pie recipe that I'm going to give
to you that you own and it becomes the
best apple pie in America and on the
back of that
we've transformed this room through here
to the alamode room come through
morning everybody how are we
can sell our own pie that's homemade
that Gordon is giving us his recipe for
oh my God this hotel invented pile of
mode and the ice cream is made fresh
here with a brand new ice cream maker
and it's
loafly sauce cream I can't wait to try
it
come with me please enjoy the apple pie
nice to see
please come through beautiful pile of
mode
digging digging come on guys
if anybody wants this you better get on
it
[Music]
oh my God that's awesome the world
famous Cambridge Hotel apple pie alamode
that is the best crust I have ever had
on a pie
welcome to the Cambridge Hotel we now
have the best apple pile of mold in I'd
say the world people are gonna be
excited
scary what do you think bud I'm shocked
you're shocked are you happy
little Lord say oh mate don't get upset
buddy
what's the matter I'm so happy oh good
I'm happy too as well you know that okay
seeing how much you change the hotel is
very overwhelming
I can feel a chance I'm a lot more
inspired right now I feel like I could
accomplish anything in the kitchen
I am proud now there's a new pride in me
to say
this is where I work
time to go I never thought I'd say this
but I'm actually quite sad to leave this
place because no longer is John in
denial he can now stand back and watch
his team run the Cambridge properly
as I'm getting ready to leave guests are
starting to arrive at the new hotel
change of all the new Decor is the fact
that guests are loving it at the
Cambridge
this is beautiful
the restaurant is buzzing Cambridge
burger with the pork belly guests are
enjoying the new home cooked menu that I
put together with Chef Rich
you better save room for the pie because
it's totally different
and the hotel's signature dish piler
mode is a big hit and that ice cream is
worth driving for fantastic
great buzz in there I mean it's electric
and it's the sound of the new Cambridge
Hotel only hope now is that they keep it
up and keep those customers excited
because when it's like that it's
phenomenal
they're good
I think tonight went incredibly well the
fact that I could stay and sit with Shay
and Addison and funk
it was really really nice
[Music]
wow
to see you smiling is incredible you
know that you light this place up but I
don't want you living here no I'm not I
don't want to live here I do not want
you living here I won't live here okay
tell him that I'm not living here I hear
you I'll give him a hug you deserves one
he hasn't interfere tonight and you sat
down and spent time with your
granddaughter I had a blast yes my job
is done let me tell you no longer
R.I.P okay of the Cambridge it has a
bright future long live the Cambridge
right absolutely right before Gordon
came I didn't know where to go anymore
with the hotel in getting Gordon here
and having him show us what the problem
was now I can see that the things can be
fixed I'll tell you okay Colin Powell
says optimism is a force multiplier
I'm optimistic stay optimistic but don't
get too involved okay okay
look after yourselves thank you very
much stay together thank you thank you
thank you
before I leave this place there's one
more person I want to talk to come on a
big man so you've got three more years
left at college right about four okay
hear me out okay I want you to keep in
touch with me okay I'll give you my
email address because I want to finance
those next four years in college
personally and help you okay do it for
you and keep that dream alive one day of
owning your bakery and then when your
bakery is open all I want back is a loaf
of bread
okay it's pretty unbelievable that he is
going to be able to finance my four
years of school well done good job thank
you so much well done I can't wait to
finish school we came off for that big
loaf of bread
you have an amazing Pair of Hands and a
lovely smile don't stop okay and God
help you if you fail that college thank
you you won't though I know you won't
well done thank you okay when I go to
school I'm gonna push myself 200 times
harder I'm gonna show her in what I can
do and how fast I can do it good night
thank you very much take care thank you
well done thank you oh good job man
awesome job hey you deserve it
definitely
what a week
what a place
and now whenever I see yellow mode I
know where it started